ينظر علينا من بيروت العميد الياس حمن
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجيه نحن اليوم
نتحدث عن تطور مختلف عن العام الماضي عن
كل التطورات منذ بدايه هذه الحرب في عام
في 24 فبراير الماضي الان العمق الروسي
كان
مستفاده قاعده عسكريه شرق موسكو
زين بالطبع حتى اغراق
موسكو وحتى قصف القواعد العسكريه في
القرن تعتبر نقاط تحول اساسيه ولكنها لا
تزال ضمن الاراضي الاوكرانيه بالمعنى
القانوني اليوم ان تقصف قاعده في الداخل
الروسي وكانك تقول ان الحرب هي ليست فقط
في اوكرانيا للشعب الروسي هي ايضا تدخل
الى روسيه وعلى عمق كبير جدا والاهم زين
هو الهدف همم قاعده
لقاذفات استراتيجيه قادره ان تحمل الرؤوس
النوويه والرئيس بوتين من فتره لاخرى يهدد
بهذا الموضوع
الوسيله هي مسيرات همم سوفيتيه هي اللي
اوكرانيا معدله على مسافات كبيره وبالتالي
هو تسكير يعني هي ليست عمليه تغيير اساسي
وجذري لموازين قوى ولكن هي رساله واصبحت
نمطا بعد ان اصبحت المره الثانيه لقصف نفس
القاعده
عميد الياس يعني بالفعل موازين القوه لولا
المسيرات لكان هناك قول اخر كما يقال الى
اي مدى بالفعل همم احدثت فرقه ان المسيرات
في قدره اوكرانيا على القيام بهذا عمليه
هذه المسايرات مياده ليست قادره على تغيير
ميازين القوى بالتاريخ الحرب والنصر هو من
يحتل الارض اليوم نتحدث حتى عن المسيرات
الايرانيه التي تستعملها روسيه لدرس
العلوم التحتيه لن تكون العامل الحاسم
العامل الحاسم عندما يستولي الرئيس بوتين
او الجيش الروسي على الدنمارس او على
اربعه اقاليم جمباز فروجيا خرسون هذا هو
الامر الاساسي ليوم المرحله هذه هي مرحله
رابعه قد نعود فيها مياده الى المرحله
الاولى يعني من اكياس حتى خرسان ولكن مع
اهداف اقل من ال- من ال- اا من اول مرحله
من هنا ياتي الاخبار عن التحدير لمعركه او
فتح جبهه من بيلاروسيا في الشمال اوكرانيا
حينما قصف جسر القرم كان رد الروسي قاسيا
باعتراف الروس اوكرانيين وقالوا الرز ان
ان هذا رد على همم جسر القرن وكان الرد في
استضاف البنيه الاساسيه الطاقه اظلام
اوكرانيا تقريبا وتقطيعه اوصالها
وقد وصلت الطائرات المسيره الى بالقرب من
موسكو كيف نتوقع الرد الروسي
يعتبر جسر كرش زين هو امر خاص وشخص للرئيس
بوتين هو من اراده صرف اربعه مليارات هو
من افتتحه وقاد السياره بنفسه يعتبر جزء
اساسي وهو المحطه من رستوب
لوجستيه الى القرم وبالتالي الى الداخل
بعد هذه الفتره اعتمدت استراتيجيه التدمير
كل البناء التحتيه طاقه مياه وكهرباء وهذا
الامر قد يكون رد على كرش ولكنه من ضمن
استراتيجيه لجعل اوكرانيا غير قادره على
خوض الحرب فاذن مع قرش والرد عليه وصلنا
الى الحد الاقصى من التصعيد مع همم مع
المسايرات وقصف القاعده ما هي الدرجه
الاعلى من هذا القصف الشامل والكامل على
اوكرانيا الا يبغى غير النووي والنوي له
حديث اخر ويعني في المرحله القادمه
جاب اعلى سقف ممكن في القدرات العسكريه
كيف نفهم حديث زنسكي عن ان الهزيمه ونهايه
الحرب لا تنتهي الا بهزيمه المعتدي هل
يمكن ذلك بالفعل
مياده هناك الخطاب الدبلوماسي والخطاب
السياسي
يترافق دائما مع ما يجري على الارض ولكن
ما يحدد موازين القوى على طاوله التفاوض
هي الانجازات على الارض الرئيس ذا لينسكي
اليوم قال ان ال- ال- الوضع في مخمود او
الوضع في الدم بس سيء جدا وهو زار او قبل
الذهاب الى زياره الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه حتى الرئيس بوتين الوزير لافراب
ديمتر بيسكوبي يقولون عن التفاوض ولكن حتى
الان الكل يريد الحد الاقصى من الاهداف
واذا اعتبرنا ان السياسه هي فن الممكن ليس
شيء ممكن حاليا اذا اراد الرئيس بوتين كل
اوكرانيا واذا ارادت همم اراد الرئيس
جيلنسكي تحرير كل الاراضي الاوكرانيات لم
نصل الى هذه المرحله بعد يعني لما يعول
على على الهزيمه يعني الا يسانده التاريخ
بعض الشيء الم ينهزم بالسوفيات في
افغانستان وين انسحب
ذلك ثوابق للسحابات روسيه همم من مناطق
استراتيجيه همم من قبل هل يمكن ان يفعلها
الروس هذه المراه
همم زين نتحدث عن افغانستان يجب ان ان
ندرس المسافه
وندرس ما يسمى همم يعني الطامبو او ما
يسمى المنطقه العازله بالتاريخ الروسي
وبالعقل الروسي افغانستان شاي ولكن بلا
روسيا شيء وهي روسيا البيضاء
واكرانيا تعتبر في العقل الروسي روسيا
الصغرى وهي روسيا الكبرى لا يمكن روسيه ان
تتخلى عن اوكرانيا بالمعنى التاريخي من
هنا كانت همم المقال الشهير الكبير قبيله
بدل الحرب من الرئيس بوتين الذي يقول لا
شيء هناك اسمه اوكرانيا ولا شيء يعتبر
سياده وهذه ارض روسيه وسنسترددها
بيروت العميد الياس حنا الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي شكرا جزيلا لك